okay we're gonna check in with Nicki
batiste now who's nearby Nicki good
morning Jeff you heard it from Governor
Scott the message here is clear get out
now or risk your life if you say the
National Weather Service is predicting
predicting potentially deadly storm
surges here anywhere from nine to 13 and
to put that into some perspective that's
about twice as high I don't know if you
can see it as this do not enter sign
over here the bay is actually just
behind these buildings right here right
now the storm surge is about four feet
we're also feeling wind gusts right now
about 33 miles per hour they're expected
to get as high as a hundred and
forty-five miles per hour when this
storm makes landfall I will tell you the
winds were so strong we just had to move
our cameras to stay safe this is a
really tiny town with old homes mobile
homes that are particularly vulnerable
in a storm like this and the residents
here are no strangers to hurricanes in
2005 Hurricane Dennis it down here is a
category three leaving two and a half
billion dollars and damage and one
resident I spoke with here who lived
through that storm said it helped better
prepare for her for this one and despite
a mandatory evacuation she has decided
to stay but the officials are very
serious they are telling residents here
do not take a chance governor Scott said
you can't hide from a storm surge Jeff
all right Nikki thank you very much